for over at least the past nine months
we've been on this amazing journey like
I think I started Jujitsu Kaizen when I
was around the 30k mark which is just
truly insane to me that we're here now
so thank you for all of the growth of
this series and others that have covered
throughout the past but yes for the
first time here we are actually catching
up to the current happenings inside of
the unforgivable world that is Jujutsu
Kaizen it's honestly really funny to me
because like every part in this story
seems to or like at least in my eyes it
seems to dwarf what happened previously
and the section of the story is no
exception in fact it sets up everything
for what I believe to be the final year
of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen especially if we
stick with what like good old Giga has
given us time frame wise but enough of
me yarning on about this amazing series
if you guys are new around here then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also push this video to 5K likes and
I'll drop the full Juju Kaizen story
like so far at least kicking off exactly
where the anime ended but either way I
hope you all enjoy the video and let's
get into the sakuna Revival Arc of Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen so remember how we leave
things with Yuji and his group at the
end of like the last period well as the
influx of American soldiers entered the
culling game a multitude of code games
appeared and began registering the
soldiers as new players elsewhere
kinjaku and arume are seen at the Zenith
Clan's Warehouse which surprisingly is
explained that there is a secret way to
transfer between colonies simply someone
could not leave a colony unless they've
answered the kogane's call unimpressed
by this automatic suggested that this
space would be more suitable as the bath
for sukuna's Revival flying back over to
the American troops as they invade
Remy's room which is just like the
biggest Alpha who are not gonna lie in
military fashion they throw flashbang
before rushing in and trying to
immobilize her with a taser allowing
them to then easily inject her with a
sedative outside a group of soldiers are
seen remarking that these Sorcerers were
nothing special and simply wondered why
their Lieutenant was so worried in the
first place rolling up we see another
group of soldiers who had taken out
their target instead of capturing it as
ordered the soldier in charge rebuked
her but the letter flippantly said that
it didn't matter since the brain was
unharmed she further complained that
literally nothing worked against the
Sorcerer And even a 50 cal bullet didn't
Pierce through the target's skin so
remember the helicopter dude usually
absolutely pummeled well that's actually
the person her Squad took out here
having heard that the dude had a
helicopter type here the soldier was
hesitant to believe her until he saw
just how damaged the female's comrades
were in the end she concluded that there
must be Sorcerers of various power
levels and she just got stuck with one
of the tougher ones which you know like
to us readers is absolutely hilarious
thinking that Harbor for some reason as
op is too good I can't actually wait
until they find a proper a grade or
above sorcerer and have to fight them in
like some kind of way funnily enough we
pop over and see the Ruffian himself
hazanoki exploding some poor
unsuspecting soldiers Vehicles as they
rolled nearby noticing that the enemy
was a foreigner the sorcerer remembered
ridge's words from earlier and wondered
if this was the bomb he suggested
kinjaku would drop now back with the
megalomaniac himself and ultimate the
letter guessed that the curse energy of
every Colony would be increased by
petting Sorcerers against Sorcerers and
any custom but for the merger with
tenkin kinjaku though admitted that what
urama had guessed there's only about 60
of his plan elaborating that the curse
energy levels in every Colony except
Tokyo and sindai were still an efficient
also kinshaku did only say that Tokyo
was the Battleground to the US so I'm
assuming that they like aren't anywhere
else in the country other than Tokyo
Colony number one or two but we're gonna
find out about that later on What's even
funnier about the military is that
kinjaku had only sent in the foreign
military as insurance and was already
aware that the fighting would not be
very intense having manifested a curse
to clean up the mess that was okizen
kinjaku claimed that unlike reincarnated
players those who had only recently
awaken their cursedness would be
reluctant to fight and the US may even
Retreat if they get too many casualties
odomay question of the military had been
sent in at night to give them an
advantage and also wonders since
non-japanese individuals would not
release curse energy so how is it
actually going to help him yet it's
actually revealed that in the moment of
passing there is an exception as the
stress of saying curses pushes them to a
new level it's also considered natural
law that non-sorcerers can't win against
Jujutsu sorcery elsewhere as one poor
poor American Soldier notices a
terrifying curse Spirit it further goes
in depth that kingjaku had released
multiple curse Spirits in every Colony
that are specifically active only at
night to force out that higher level of
cursed energy from these new soldiers
back over with the main crew now Angel
quickly deduced at kingjaku heads into
non-sorcerers to be killed by curse
Spirits as a Fail-Safe to produce more
curse energy having left the room now
and made their way down some stairs the
group ran into an empty cafeteria right
as a stunning grenade lands in front of
them obviously thrown by the military
boys noticing it Yuji quickly kicks the
flesh being away before it could explode
in front of them seeing the squad pull
up migami initially assumed that his
soldiers were trying to protect people
but instantly discarded the possibility
as these Soldiers with their second
thought began shooting at the sorcerers
abruptly with anything to skip away and
see what seems to be the past memory for
make her spirit feeding three young
children inside of an abandoned building
then back with a group all of a sudden
we see good old Mega me interrogating a
Japanese soldier who was actually acting
as a guide for the foreign military
forces when henna asks why Japan had not
taken the opportunity to become energy
self-sufficient sooner the soldier
responds that Jujutsu headquarters
controlling the country is too proud and
everyone here is obsessed with
self-responsibility so it never ever
would caught on like it would have in
other countries it can be also realized
that kinjaku had only lured the military
to the colonies under the false proteins
that curse energy was up for grabs as
another energy source from thus Mickey
with introduces that this soldier's
death would increase the curse energy
and their colonies and complete the
ritual preceding tinga's merger with the
wider Japanese population making me you
know like obviously it's so damn big
brain that the dude even suspects that
King Jacob has likely orchestrated the
culling game as a distraction for his
true plan stepping in Yuji asks if they
should help them prompted to Kaba to ask
why they should even help people who
wanted to abduct them for experiments
making me reasons that if they allow
kinjaku to fulfill the ritual everyone
would be caught up in the merger with
tingen yet Angel Cuts in telling them
that it's no use since Tokyo Colony 1
has already reached their required level
of curse energy Yuji challenges Angel's
decision though stating that it did not
invalidate their saving of other
people's lives the letter tries
explaining to Yuji though that it has a
symbiotic relationship with its vessel
so putting henna at unnecessary risk is
akin to put any curse living within her
body at risk itself shooting over with
into the true Terror that some soldiers
are being put through after having fun
with its first Soldier the predatory
curse then picked up its next prey which
just happened to be the same Japanese
soldier the group was interrogating
before laying there and suspecting the
worst this Soldier thinks back on the
times he had believed that he was ready
to pass on but feels it now this is
different and seeing what awaits him
truly shatters his resolve nearby Eugene
migami just happened to be running
through an Alleyway Megami insists to
his boy that he doesn't need to be so
hostile and asks a Fuji's comment about
not trusting henna was a reference to
bands like sakuna an angel skipping away
for a moment and referring back to the
random like flashback that we had just
before well it was actually Hannah as a
child sadly she had been forced to live
with that cursed spirit for almost a
year eventually though she managed to
escape after following a white dog with
a fluffy tail of course it was no one
other than megami's white Divine dog who
had little to safety before returning to
him in Gojo as henna watches the three
reunite and begin to leave and flashes
back to the prison as she remembers the
kind nurse because of their moment
during her childhood she decided to try
and help people herself as she's always
believed that someday they would meet
again and she would proudly stand by her
side all Mega me wanted was for Yuji to
be a bit more considerate twitch like
after hearing all of this a boy
confesses that ever since they regrouped
he was just scared that Hannah would
take no virus place what you know I'm a
lord Giga we actually got similar crumbs
for the first time in like how long it's
we're damn fiends out here absolutely
wanting anything to do with her or Gojo
man just come on come on please anyway
it's making me scold shuji and asks him
to apologize to Hannah the queen herself
appears before the boys bringing the
crew fully back together let the
ripening begin if you guys know what I
mean then you know what I mean it's huge
beings of light suddenly emerged from
every Colony throughout Japan that can
detract in the attention of everyone
throughout the entire country not
understanding what's happening many
people just know that something doesn't
feel right like the ear had become a
naturally dry returning to our crew Maki
gives everyone a full rundown of
everything that's happened up to this
point she explained that chose who had
managed to protect the back of the
prison realm but relay the news of
Yuki's defeat in tingen's capture in
another location our boy choso clutchini
bet gay or literally hope itself in this
case here I guess weeps as Carrara asked
him about Yuki's whereabouts pretty much
to me at least confirming her demise
Maki further told the first two years
that the ritual precedingly merger had
already ended calmly Mikey concluded
that taking down the villain would be a
challenge leading Yuji to wonder how
they merge ahead and actually started
Angel points out to the group that the
sorcerers inside of the colonies could
probably reject the merger with tenken
because of their cursed energy so
because of that nothing is going on
around them being able to travel inside
and out of the barriers herself though
Mucky disagrees and informs them that
apart from a few affected people most of
Japan's population is unaffected as of
now making me suspect that deccanjaku
either couldn't start the mooji yet or
didn't want to however since there was
no way to find out right now they
decided to focus on friends to make me
first intervening in the conversation
himself Juju decides to list off the
four rules that they decided to
implement mikami again clarifies that
rule 1 does indeed subject a player to
acoustic removal or subsequently death
through something missing with their
brain the purpose of this first rule was
just the star fights with people but now
they can obviously circumvent theirs
Mucky though remarked that it was
actually rules two and three which were
the tricky ones as they involved somehow
creating a form of movement and
communication across colonies stepping
forth herself henna declares that she
could move across the colonies by virtue
of Angel's curse technique Mahi asked if
it's possible that she could use a curse
technique on someone else to help them
leave but the voice of Angel replied
that they could only extinguish a
barrier technique by destroying the root
of the barrier itself if they can't
locate these so-called rote they're only
able to pass through the colonies
without actually destroying them with
the group realizing that adding new
rules might not actually allow them to
move across colonies that decide to add
the fourth Rule and focus on allowing
players to withdraw from the game
entirely so earlier on an Ulta was back
well like Megami was recovering user had
transferred all the accumulated points
over to migami bringing his total number
of points up to 359. by the way there is
actually like a tiny mess up by gear
right here notice that it already says
one rule while Giga had messed up and
spoiled everyone in some kind of way
letting them know that Megami did indeed
Implement at least one rule speaking of
himself Megami attempts to add a rule
allowing players to withdraw from the
game but cocaine rejects it stating that
it clashed against roll seven Mega me
tried a game asking if the game master
would allow players to withdraw if they
invited a substitute and the colony to
take their place but still cocaine
refused however out of nowhere it
actually states that the culling game
has a suggestion it says that it would
indeed let players leave the game on the
condition that they provided one
substitute and spent 100 points unable
to negotiate any further and utterly
paved with the result making me agree
despite knowing that Ed in the new rule
would require them to take out at least
another 20 Sorcerers to just leave with
all of the negotiations complete mikami
created a new rule rule 11 a player can
leave the game by expending 100 points
to invite a new player into the colony
as a substitute looking over to the clan
killer herself which they don't actually
realize there are monkeys even taken out
of Clan yet mikimi asks if it's okay for
her to transport sakumi to Tokyo Colony
number one Yuji asked though if it would
be safer to transfer the points to her
remotely since she was already outside
the colonies however Megami pointed out
that since the rules illicitly stated
that a player must declare their
participation in a colony within 19 days
trying to circumvence it might lead to a
sister being sent subject acoustic
technique removal when she tries to
leave the game flashing forth now to the
fateful day of November the 16th we see
that after reconnecting with samiki Mahi
led her and the assistant manager ojichi
to the outskirts of Tokyo Colony number
one so when it actually comes to who's
going to be the substitute for uh said
making here achichi had previously
agreed to take the role due to marky's
lack of curse energy as it prevents the
barrier from even recognizing her or
allowing her to become a substitute so
Miki is visibly conflicted by the idea
but ajichi reason that they didn't have
enough time to find someone out as it
had literally been 16 days since
everything began literally only given
her three days before like her brain
goes poof standing there ajichi
reminisces on past memories and how they
always wanted to be a source where they
helped people yet goju demanded that he
get his license and become a manager
instead back then ajichi had thought the
sorcerer to be harsh but now he realized
that he would have been dead by now if
he continued down that path he had
previously chosen so he thanks Gojo for
putting him on the right track so
remember like the spawn glitch Yuji and
mega me previously went through back a
little bit well somehow I don't even
know how she managed to do this but to
me he hacked the game and got insanely
lucky appearing directly before Megami
and Yuji upon entering the barrier
completely stunning to both of them with
no time to lose let me not even speaking
to her transferred 100 points to a
sister asking her to declare her
withdrawal from the game however to the
complete and utter shock to me he used
the points to instead add a new rule to
the game she immediately makes the 12th
rule granting players and restricted
entry and exit across Colony borders
more to fight and literally just
standing there unable to Fathom what
just happened Mega me asks his green
sister Who and the oil she really was
I wonder so have you ever felt pain and
those few moments before what we now
know his pain crawled its way out of the
dark abyss itself Yuji had just assumed
everything was sweet now samiki was safe
migami would be all right and you would
follow up after and then kill sakona
along with Yuji and release Gojo who
would in turn take care of kinjaku the
plan literally had no folds apart from
the fact that they don't own the playing
field that they're standing on I'm
honestly at the point right now that I
think they just lose here the story ends
on a sad no and will be the first Shonen
to do so with all of the bad guys
winning unless like somehow Gojo gets
out and goes utterly god mode that
that's the only way they win right now
in my eyes it's totally crazy however
samiki was then revealed to be an
imposter watching this thing in front of
him cackle Megami asks the Imposter who
they are Twitchy hysterically gloats
that she's definitely his big sister
stricken and at a loss for words Megami
remembers that the incarnated players
are given access to the memories of
their host thus because of their it's
entirely possible for them to
impersonate their hosts feeling like a
complete idiot now Mega meeperates
himself forever thinking that his sister
had automatically awakened like hagaroma
and takaba so this person inside of Mega
me is actually called igorozu a sorcerer
from at least 1 000 years ago just like
a few of the other people here mikimi
who obviously just wants to know why is
told as she pretended to be his big
sister to use the three points for her
own game she hasn't had a good fight in
at least a thousand years and wants to
choose her battle along with this
location claiming that she wants to take
on sakuna first moth like wings begun
forming on her back before she jumps off
the building and begins boosting away
Yuji and Hannah like instantly go to
give Chase not wanting her to escape
however like everyone plays just
remember back episode 7 right here and
right now already in a moment of Despair
sukuna uses that opportunity to appear
on the side of yuji's face and utterly
words in chain as per the bunny Val
showing in chapter 11 or episode 7 you
he is intently forced to hand over his
body to sukuna without any hesitation
sakuna immediately appears on the back
of henna taking her out for the complete
ease looking over at me and me whose
brain must be going through it right now
so Corner explains that he once made a
vowel with Yuji having explained that he
can't harm anyone to Mega me he knows
they're from here on out everything that
he does is just a complete gamble
sending some form of like channeling
curse energy to yuji's finger sukuna
then proceeds to freaking tear his
entire finger off screaming at this
moment and like pure joy he explained
that it was a gamble because he wasn't
even sure if Yuji included himself in
the veil when stipulating the condition
that zakona must not hurt anyone mega
mega me typical man like instantly pulls
out the arm movements to do maharaga but
I honestly can't blame him he doesn't
really have any other choice at the
moment so as he tries to summon maharaga
zakuna Datsun graving his face and
restricting the summoning seal before
shoving his finger down her boy's
unsuspecting throat with the cursed
energy pulse 18 through Mega me an
unconscious Yoji comes to not even
realizing what just happened as as per
the vowel stipulations however standing
opposite his boy he hears sakuna say
that indeed he's something interesting
in the future didn't they raising his
head we say that no one other than the
king of curses himself has supposedly
fully reincarnated inside of Megami for
shiguru's body well they're just Heaven
boys and at this moment we very possibly
could have lost yet another of the
original Trio yet in my eyes we can't
lose them we can't lose them all unless
the bad guys actually win in the series
so if down the line it's confirmed and
the bath is completed and everything has
just turned to utter trash remind me
that hope itself was utterly sucked out
of the series at this exact moment
please just come back and let me know
down below anyway going back probably
for a last time I would say into the
inner world of sukonas we see him
monologue about the intricacies of his
plan for Mega me back during the day
when he confronted Mega me as Yuji for
the first time he sensed unmatched
Potential from him his acoustic Knicks
and his abilities he knew that he could
have forced Mega me to eat his finger
then and there that day but it
purposefully waited until build up
enough strength instead of Yuji to
initiate the vowel actually they have a
great Theory here and like how we all
know that kinjaku had made Yuji
specifically forskona well what if
kinjaku also made it a binding Veil that
yuchi would not be able to use his curse
technique while sakuna was caged inside
of him but sakuna finally leaving our
boy's body now we may see for the first
time that Yuji actually like has his
mother's technique or possibly something
that even relates to a literal thing
that'll bring up right at the very end
of this video anyway I top the building
miguna which is like sukuna Mega me mix
up I'm just gonna call him that
sometimes the absolute Beast himself
stands there leaving Yuji stunned asking
for his friend to just talk to him yet
as we all probably expected was just
about to happen the demon Megami asukuna
comes in will they charge and punches
Yuji like and this wasn't any ordinary
level of punch as well meant to
separated the fabric around the area
that he hit on Yuji like it made Yuji
freaking throw up while sending him
hurling through a multitude of different
skyscrapers eventually though Yuji ends
up finishing his destructive path on a
rooftop of another building completely
unconscious and covered in rubble
noticing some people approaching the
area sukuna states that in every damn
age and sex always come crawling out of
the woodwork placing his hands together
it informs the sign of megami's tin
Shadows technique more specifically the
hand signs for no way instantly a
monolithic sized Norway is summoned out
of a nearby Skyscraper with everyone
reacting in pure shock and or at the
size of no way it releases it's usually
pretty ineffective attack that simply
stuns people yet this time it rains
deadly lightning down on everyone from
the sky above having recovered from a
previous beating henna quickly makes
your appearance by shooting over showing
up behind the revive demon saying her
sakuna realizes that Hannah and the
angel co-exist and thus she can recover
very fast to say like in comparison to
him and Yuji in the past given that
Hannah is extremely in love with me give
me I would say probably from what I've
read so far she screams and hesitation
not wanting to hurt Mega me however
Angel insists that there is no other
choice he is the disgraced one and must
be eliminated right away thus as Hannah
cries to get migami back Angel becomes
reciting the Incarnation to dispel evil
itself speaking to God now she tells him
to purify all remove his anguish
transgressions and guilt to guide him on
the correct path instantly Jacobs later
initiates filling the sky with some form
of holy symbol before a mess of pure
light energy strikes down upon the
disgraced one himself in another note
boys just quickly cutting in here and
after browsing the interwebs myself I'll
discover that Jacob's letter is actually
referring to a line from Genesis 28
10-19 I don't know if that's actually I
think that's how you say uh Bible lines
I shouldn't know I used to I was raised
in the church this part of like the
Bible narrates the story of Jacob
dreaming of the Angels descending from
the heavens and the letter appearing to
take these Souls from Earth to heaven so
in other words the attack simply
dispelled evil while sending the
person's soul on the correct path or at
least that's however interpreted her
attack as with the mass of light bearing
down on mcgone that begins tearing at
zakuna's soul in an attempt to bring
migami back as Hannah is crying
screaming that Mega me belongs to her it
appears as if the technique has actually
managed to work dispelling sakuna's
Spirit from migami's body but remember
like honestly hit just how I said before
that incarnated Sorcerers and people
like sukuna can mimic how their body
used to behave while Angel realizes that
sukuna is still in control and
manipulating henna with migami's voice
not paying attention though henna falls
into Miguel's arms saying that she's
always sadly though she's unable to
continue her sentence has sakona fully
reveals himself before going to strike
on an unsuspecting henna calling her a
foolish human shakuna like an absolutely
rabid dog bites in tears at Hannah
before throwing her across the entirety
of the building causing her to smash
into the side of the protective railing
Yuji down below watching this in shock
and not even able to comprehend what
just happened Witnesses Hannah thud onto
the ground below with no indication that
she'll ever return looking down from the
top of the building himself zakuna is
astonished to see you Fuji somehow alive
after the previous blow with rage
beginning to fill up inside of him and
after realizing that he's lost the one
thing keeping him together and giving
him meaning in life Yuji breaks and a
complete flash usually jumps across the
building breaking the ground below him
and causing the entire skyscraper to
collapse he Graves to Cone his neck and
screams his name before landing a
ferocious punch on the king of cursor's
face forcing him to dub back across the
street for gaining his footing sakuna
wonders just just how any world uses so
strong all of a sudden then in that
freaking moment Yuji takes him off guard
throwing a massive section of the
previously collapsing building into the
Demon's face seeing him shooting back
once again sprinting towards them
himself yuhi grabs a piece of rebar to
beat down onto Kona worth with him
darting him behind the king of curses
Schooner remarks that he should have
seen us coming after all Yuji is from
back then and what do you mean by that
sakuna right there eh anyway having
blocked yuji's strike with the bar
sakuna counters by disarming and kicking
him in the face while noting that King
is Twisted I'll expand like more on what
this means in a moment but honestly in
my opinion this all relates back to Yuji
and him having his curse techniques
suppressed or I like it being suppressed
while he was being used as a cage for
his Kona so don't be surprised if our
guy manages to manifest and in the
Heritage technique in the near like very
near future but yeah asuji continues to
approach to Kona trying to attack him he
screams asking him why why is it that he
just can't live normally like everyone
else why can't he live a life without
causing everyone to suffer Yuji
continues approaching when all of a
sudden takuna uses his curse technique
slash to cut Yuji across the chest
replying to his previous statement
sukuna rebuttals him asking him why so
weak continuously trying to cling to
life he continues by saying that this
suffering is only natural and they are
meant to live life with this misery for
a moment there Yuki forgot that there is
no reasoning with him as they are and
always will be curses do he dares to
Kona to chew on his misery and suffering
instead while beginning to March towards
the damn Lord himself passing him off is
just absolutely pathetic zakuna uses his
curse technique to continuously cut Yuji
over and over and over and over again
yet our boy is just built different and
with a rage-filled heart he puts the
pain aside and stuns sukuna by not
slowing his Approach at all standing
there and actually confused now on like
like what is going on shakuna wonders
how in the world is so tough then out of
freaking nowhere and just like during
Shibuya once again proving that the body
and soul are won making me hold sukuna's
movement allowing his boy to follow up
and Pamela's face with a fat right Hawk
elsewhere and literally just boasting it
over on the Blowfish Express ultimate in
kanjaku are seen traveling towards what
I assume to be the current bait down
back in the battle and having smack
sakuna in the face maguna remarks that
fushiguro is indeed stopping his curse
energy output which is allowing him to
only use 10 of his maximum output hence
how Yuji has managed to survive the
blows so far sakuna notes that well it's
probably expected when the jobs only
half done but still considers it enough
to easily take out ug interesting so I
wonder what the other half of this
ritual to fully take over megami's body
will be probably something to do with
the bath and that'll happen at these in
his household which is their fitting
scene at Megami is actually like from
the Xena's bloodline and all standing
there maguna is completely taken by
surprise as he couldn't see to Maki
actually slowly moving towards the
epicenter of the fight I want you to
know what in the world corsicona's body
to switch into migamese Maki asks to be
brought up to date with Yuji just
completely bedded and bruised telling
her to just kill him as he's not going
to die either way Boosie then Marky
attempts to land a fat head kick in
collaboration with Yuji however mikimi's
body is functioning extremely well
obviously you know from what we've seen
so far and he's comfortably able to
counter his opponent still Mahi with her
immense speed is able to break through
his defenses and send him flying
smashing into some railing nearby taking
the opportunity juji think grabs the
other side of the railing beats in it
around sakuna before Mikey follows up in
combination and kicks him into a
building nearby sending the unharmed
Damon walks out though Maggie wonders if
it's impossible to actually inflict
damage with his sole Liberation sword
because sakuna will use his reverse
curse techniques to heal himself knowing
that no matter what happens here they'll
have to kill sakuna Maki charges insane
he'll have to keep up with his speed
probably running its pitch faster than
sound right now sukuna is surprisingly
able to keep up with the attacks of Maki
and hugee but knows that whenever he
tries to attack them with curse energy
they pull from Mega me inside him is
stronger and thus to get around megame
sakuna like the absolute big brain man
he is uses his curse technique cleave
spider threads on the ground below to
utterly destroy the ground and
disbelance Yuji and Marquee with the
ground around them now falling to butt
zakuna is able to easily Dart in and
Leslie fat right Hawk yet Maki simply
spits out a tooth or two leaving him
completely impressed with how she's
hardly even worried with taking damage
asakuna falls back a little a mysterious
fold and randomly appears from the side
and uses a maximum output technique
called Dead Calm the resulting aftermath
from Tech not only freezes the entirety
of the area but also Marky and Eugene so
their mysterious person happened to be
no one other than the coldest woman out
sakuna's right-hand woman uramae who
apologizes for a grand entrance while
saying that she's still awakened the ice
around Yuji just in case they need him
sukuna though literally doesn't care for
him anymore and instead just compliment
to her stay tuned they're focusing her
energy on Maki was a good idea believing
that everything here is sweet now sukuna
then summons no way saying that this
body is still not complete so they need
to prepare for the bath immediately in
that moment though our goat though
looking more beta than Bros than ever
after this Escalade burst his way out of
the ice noticing this or maybe proposes
taking him out but shakuna says that
they should just look at him and have a
good laugh flying away for what seems
like good in yuji's eyes sukuna having
taken the body of yuji's best friend and
uramae laugh at his face noticing that
he looks just like the person from The
harima Province which is exactly what I
was referring to and goes back to
kinjaku using a binding vowel on Yuji at
Birth or even beforehand The Vow would
not allow him to use this technique in
return for Yuji being used as a vessel
for zakuna to help restore his strength
obviously we know that kinjaku would
like purposely found a bloodline that
has some form of durability as was seen
in Yuji possibly to just keep sukuna
safe during his time in Yuji announced
confirmed that Yuji actually has true
Heritage that originates from a family
in the harima province and this harima
province was established in the 600s A.D
and ran up to the late 1800s so
definitely before like the current time
period so you all thought the arc ended
here well no no no sakuna is Megami
actually speed ran this damn bath and
after having arrived at the xenon's
household we see him falling deeper and
deeper into evil itself outside the bath
urume dressed up in ritual robes asks
hinjaku whether or not he plans to end
the Cullen game twitch kinjaku explains
that his assimilation of The Wider
population can't actually Heaven until
the game ends the recently culling game
was even able to be constructed in the
first place was because kingjaku had
shouldered the burden of an equally
unreasonable binding vowel yet instead
of getting on with Indina currently he's
more interested in sakona's bath and how
it works kinjaku himself knew that the
bath was originally a ritual to
transform vessels that had been
treasured as family heirlooms into
cursed holes to do this the clay must
make a solution of curse energy which
was created by straining organisms
chosen in a kodoku ritual once it has
prepared the vessels are soaked for 10
months in 10 days and the solution so
what's actually really cool about this
ritual is it's actually something from
real Japanese folklore it's a derivative
of the Chinese go magic and it's a type
of poisonous ability and how real life
to create kodoku Sorcerers would mix
civil insects in HR and let them kill
one another until only one survived the
fluids of the insect that survived will
be used to poison an individual with a
curse that would control them causing
Misfortune or kill them the remaining n6
would also be used as a sort of luck
charm granting the one who performed the
ritual great wealth this ritual could
also be used as a death curse by giving
the riches to an ignorant individual
perhaps like kinjaku if the uh if he's
ignorant enough in this example here but
I don't actually think he is the term
kodoku can also be applied to the spirit
which is the Incarnation of this
particular magic funnily enough this
technique was even used in the Nara
period in like real life which we now
know as the era just before the Golden
Age of sorcery introduced to Kaizen so
kinjaku was actually surprised that they
specifically chose to use curses in this
ritual especially for the fact that they
become dust upon their deaths urume
though like the cold queen that she is
actually figured out a way to get around
verse simply if she carefully pins down
the spirits before freezing the cause
they don't turn into dust and it allows
them to strain away the toxins they need
confused with the purpose of it all
kinjaku asks why and urma just tells him
as to get closer to evil the entire
purpose of this ritual is to suppress
migami fushiguru's Soul deeper into the
deeps as they further down and he thinks
the easier it is for sakonas to control
the cage he's currently controlling
having completed the bath the Demon Lord
himself rises from the depths of evil
symbolizing that migami fujiguro has
lost his small hold he head over sakona
hinjaku questions why didn't change his
appearance but sakuna just reasons that
if he's gonna be battling Sorcerers then
it's better to maintain migami's
appearance honestly this is just
probably for the fact that whenever he
runs into a group of people from like
Jujutsu High it'll just completely and
utterly shatter their resolve as he
never actually expected something like
this would ever happen so remember
samiki which is now you got to do well
it was actually a dude that reincarnated
inside of her and after leaving Yuji
they'll travel back to their Hometown
before later heading to the Sendai
colony which was the closest uh I guess
barrier to it having got the rundown on
this from kinjaku sukuna says that he
doesn't give a damn about Yoda Zoo but
instead wants to destroy samiki for
shigaro to completely sink migami Soul
inside of him as they're being leave on
the Blowfish Express kinjaku tells him
that he'll give him a ride to the Colony
but once he points an exchange so I
truly wonder what on the world he's
about to do with the 200 or so points
that he's just received from sukuna here
let me know your thoughts on that down
below do you reckon he's going to like
actually pay for himself to to leave the
game entirely and just let everyone else
do their thing while he causes Havoc
outside of like the colonies and stuff
but anyway I'd love to know your
thoughts down below two team back to the
Sendai Colony for the first time in a
while both uro and Ryu notice a mass of
bloodlust appear from afar uro utterly
breaks down muttering that here he comes
the king of curses instantly sukuna
arrives in front of Ryu and as he slowly
begins walking up to him he asks if he's
gonna run or not but before Ryu could
even act sakuna activates a slash
technique and slashes Rio across the
chiest blown away though because he like
obviously thought he was going to get
cut into a multitude of Paces so
couldn't just laughs and apologizes
saying that he underestimated Ryu but
won't hold back again filling the
bloodlust Rising Ryu jumps back and
tries to use Granite blast but before he
could even finish his attack sequence
sukuna slices Ryu across the face
absolutely destroy one of my favorite
characters in typical Giga fashion
having left the area that he was just at
and now arriving at a football field in
Sendai zakuna finally encounters Yoda
Zoo
standing there and after realizing this
akona's stolen someone else's body and
switched so Kona just remarks that this
dude's face looked much better and damn
like oh I don't know if you guys could
obviously hear but between the time that
2 15 and 216 came out I got covered and
I'm absolutely terribly ill right now so
I hope the end of this wasn't too bad
but what a way to revive the king of
curses himself obviously you know from
what we've seen and read here he isn't
fully revived here and has chosen to
just keep the form of Mega me until he
can completely subdue the student's Soul
I'd love to know what your thoughts on
the sarc are so make sure you let me
know down below and if you are new
around here and want to watch a bunch of
content just like this but for a variety
of different series then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also turn
that Bell notification on also I'll be
re-scripting and re-editing the entirety
of the Gojo past Arc over the next few
days for the full jjk story video so for
all of my longtime subscribers it feels
like a brand new video that you guys
like get it doesn't just feel like I'm
rehashing eight or so videos together
but anyway if you guys do want earlier
access to that then check out my page
patreon and I've also like had a few
comments in the past asking to like put
my videos into podcast format so I've
gone and done that for everyone and set
up a Spotify and all that kind of jazz
and if you're interested then the link
for there is ordered in the description
below but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and
thank you for all of the support on
absolutely everything so far but I'll
see you all in a bit bye